we're now well into the first week of
februari 2015 so I'm doing another
monthly ramp up and prospective and
update video where I'll talk about what
we had going on in January and what
we've got coming up in February there
are a few things that I would like to
put out there right away before i talk
about january just to keep them fresh in
people's mind and maybe give you a
little teaser about what we've got to
talk about 44 februari but some of these
are things that are ongoing as well so
I've got three free events in this the
local area one down in the city in New
York City and two here in Kingston in
the Hudson Valley of New York so if
you're in the area consider popping by
for those put them on your calendar I'll
talk about those in the februari section
I'm still continuing and expanding the
tutoring and the philosophical
counseling so if you want to have a
one-on-one engagement with me where
you're studying philosophy you can do
that either through google helpouts or
since it's not available for some people
we're not convenient for some people you
can do that directly via Skype with me
and I'll put more information on talk a
bit more about that in the februari
section philosophical counseling that's
that's going along quite well getting
more clients for that so if you're
interested in that sort of thing you can
you can email me up Greg at reason I oh
or you can follow you know the the
information that I'm going to provide
here as well what else do I want to put
on your your radar I started the the
existentialism a plain old class and
I'll talk a bit more about that in the
februari section it's that the time for
enrolling for that class is over but
we'll have another section of it opening
up down the line for those who missed it
the first time so on to January a lot
going on in January I've been to public
lectures one was in the new understand
ending anger lecture series that's going
to run the entire year of 2015 you might
remember that I did a similar lecture
series with the Kingston library over
2014 on existentialist thought called
glimpses into existence and that started
to get a lot of regulars coming in and a
lot of new people towards the end so
we're getting you know a larger space
for this and I'm getting better about
doing the you know public promotion
stuff that I really need to do this one
is focused on anger as its depicted and
discussed in philosophy literature and
religious texts from the ancient period
all the way through the late Middle Ages
so where we began with Greek tragedy and
epic you know Homer Ashla Sophocles
Euripides and we're going to finish up
towards the very end withdraw sir and
Dante and we're going to do a lot of
stuff in between so in January we did
like I said Greek epic and tragedy you
can see the video for that and we'll
have a lot more coming up with her you
know with in that series I also did an
evening lecture at the unitarian
universalist community of the Catskills
which which hosted a talk that I gave on
radio maria rilke and his poetry and his
letters and his views on the divine and
that was that was quite a good event as
well very icy snowy evening but we had a
pretty good-sized crowd of 20 who came
to brave the cold had a lot of useful
meetings and I'll probably talk more
about those in later update videos when
they start burying their fruit I did
some philosophical counseling some some
tutoring over the last month I did a lot
of online teaching I had three marys
classes going at the beginning of
January thankfully to them finished up
because they were four week intensive
ethics classes two of them finished up
about mid month and it took me about a
week to recover from
the the energy that I had to pour into
having 75 students in a compressed
period where two of those classes are
doing 16 weeks or the work in four weeks
and one of the classes which still is
going on right now is doing 16 weeks in
10 weeks so that took a lot of time and
work for the for the the ten week class
I've been developing all brand new
content for that and down the line I'll
probably offer that in some other format
in a public way so that people who you
know are enrolled in marys can actually
follow along with that I also took an
online class towards the end of the
month with a new platform is based in
Britain and it was hosted by the
University of Birmingham the Jubilee
Center for character for character and
virtue i think it's called character
ethics and it was on character education
and i have much more application to the
british context than necessarily to an
american context but it was quite good
and it's nice to be a student sometimes
rather than having to be the professor
you know I was coming into the class as
somebody who does virtue ethics work as
as a an expert as but you know for a
living but you know it's nice to be able
to sit back and see what other people
are doing I learned a few things it was
really interesting seeing what my fellow
participants were writing in the
discussion boards and I actually did a
sort of review of the class itself in my
blog virtue ethics digest so if you're
interested in that you can see that I'll
put the link to it there video work I I
only did work in my main channel this
month I didn't get around to adding more
content to the critical thinking read
critical thinking logic and
argumentation channel and just in parks
I didn't have enough time and I was
doing so much video work for the world
views and values class but I did bring
out a
of half hour Hagel videos midway through
the month we are now right smack dab in
the middle of the new section sense
certainty so you know that's kind of
cool that we're getting that far I did
shoot a lot of world views and values
videos and I've released some of them I
think some of the play doh videos i was
still releasing in january i know i
released quite a few on Epictetus and
quite a few on Boethius boethius is
consolation of philosophy is not a text
that I've done videos on before so
that's brand new content the epictetus
some of it overlaps with some earlier
videos but quite a bit of it as new as
well writing I was able to get some
writing done one of the things I wanted
to do this year is really start blogging
again in earnest something that I did in
the past that I really enjoyed I have
right now if you count the half hour
Hagel five blogs there's a main blog or
xst in 20 k and then there's a for more
specialized blogs there's virtue ethics
digest obviously about virtue ethics
Sandler's existentialism updates
obviously about existentialism heavy
metal philosopher much more music
oriented sometimes the stuff and there
isn't even strictly philosophical it's
more about heavy metal and then half
hour Hagel very very focused on that
series of blog that I created in order
to curate the the videos because they're
you know we're now at number 40 so
there's there's quite a few of them but
I've been blogging regularly in those at
least got one entry done last month for
each of them I've been working on
revising and expanding my paper that a
game on an some mercy justice and and
God in incurred a homo because that's
going to get published fairly soon I've
been working on some Aristotle stuff as
well and I'm still working on the sample
chapter for the good life textbook
didn't get as much done on that as I
wanted to in that one I'm writing about
money specifically you know making money
spending money saving money all those
sorts of things
so that's what went on during January
you can tell it's a pretty packed month
now on to what we've got coming up in
February so like I said we have three
public events that are actually free of
charge so if you're in the area and
you've got free time and you'd like to
you know attend these don't come on over
and and and do so if you do so by the
way introduce yourself to me afterwards
if I don't already know you so we have
the next understanding anger lecture
that is actually coming up on the
fourteenth on Valentine's Day you might
say well you know why are you talking
about anger on Valentine's Day what
better day you know because somebody's
going to get in get somebody but we're
actually doing it in the morning you
know if we are if the smarter thing
would actually be to do it on the day
after valentine's day after people have
screwed up but this isn't actually not
about valentine's day at all joking
about that it's really focused on anger
in in the Jewish Scriptures so we're
looking at you know the wisdom
literature we're looking at some of the
narratives particularly the first murder
you know Cain and Abel and we're looking
at depictions of divine wrath in that
that's what we're focusing on this month
so that that's about an hour of lecture
which is always you know interpenetrated
by a lot of discussion and then the last
half an hour's just straight-out
discussion they have to at the kingston
library and you can see the event links
will also be doing something that that's
brand new and i'm doing this with a
colleague and one of his colleagues
we're starting a new series partnering
with the kingston library called
reconsidering so this month it's going
to be reconsidering ferguson for Black
History Month and i'll be doing a talk
about 15 minutes portion there about
Martin Luther King and his conception of
just and unjust law and how we want to
understand things like policing you know
rules and regulations all that sort of
stuff some of the other participants are
going to talk about other things there's
going to be a big focus on promoting
group discussion of these so that the
talks are sort of just to give anchor
points for the the larger discussion
next month we'll be doing reconsidering
Charlie Hebdo and we'll be doing more of
these reconsidering each month down the
line that one's going to be on the 18th
at the kingston public library at six
o'clock ending a little bit before eight
o'clock then I'm also going to be doing
something quite exciting with my my
first event in the city in New York City
which is long overdue I been invited
down to give a lecture to the mead
anderson undergraduate philosophy forum
at columbia university and i'll be
talking about Aristotle and anger and
how it is that anger is able to seduce
rationality but also how anger is
connected with rationality for Aristotle
so I'll put it you know event
information about that that will be on
the twenty-fifth of februari which is a
wednesday at 8pm so I'm coming all the
way down to the city for that and I
won't be sticking around afterwards i'll
be taking the train back home or getting
a ride because I you know I've got to
work the next day but I will be down in
the city during that day probably around
the Columbia campus hanging out with
some of the people who are hosting so
you know that may be a good opportunity
if you've always wanted to meet me and
talk with me to do so i'll be continuing
is probably be doing the rest of my life
my philosophical counseling practice
which is now starting to take off and
tutoring where we've actually worked out
a kind of price arrangement where people
can not only you know go through google
but also just by tutoring slots where I
give a price break if you buy five hours
or 10 hours at a time depending on what
you want to do so I've got clients for
instance who want
you do a course of study and I do that
with them in order to help them with
their lifelong learning or their
professional development so if your
interest in that sort of thing I've got
links here for that another big thing in
February it's been long awaited and I
have had a number of you know sort of
self-imposed delays but I finally
started teaching the existentialism
class for a player know that I started
developing over a year ago and we're in
the first week of it we've had a couple
meetings by videoconference already the
students are exploring the resources and
the website that I've put together for
them we've had some great discussions
already and so I'm really looking
forward to the next 11 weeks of this
class we're going to be doing
Kierkegaard next week and we're going
all the way through to Gabrielle Marcel
what else we've got some major projects
and partnerships that were in discussion
about this month and I don't want to say
too much about them quite yet because
they could be falling through but I can
tell you about one that that took place
in part last month and we're going to be
continuing some some you know
discussions and work over the coming
months there's there's a very
interesting guy who is bringing out a
site called scholar printer he's an
adjunct who is making a living not only
adjunct Inge but also you know
self-publishing developing courses he
works in history and he's got a really
great model and he's starting a blog and
he's starting you know sort of a site
and service so I like what he's doing I
did an interview with him last month and
we're going to keep in touch about that
what else did we got going on so videos
this is probably the thing that you're
most interested in because you know
you're watching the video channel the
half-hour Hagel series we are on track
to finish up with the the section sense
certainty and two
you ready to move into perception which
is the next section in the phenomenology
of spirit come March so actually making
some good progress I'm going to be
shooting some existentialism videos and
I'm also going to be revising some of
the older existentialism videos where
the sound and that the the lighting
isn't quite up to snuff I'm going to be
editing those and improving them and
perhaps adding a few things in here and
there but I'm going to be putting the
new edited ones into a new channel that
I'm starting and I'm going to wait until
they're all in there and then I'll sort
of open it up but i will be doing some
other new new work on that world views
and values i still have a lot of videos
that I've been shooting from my current
mayor of students that i'll be releasing
over this month and also into next month
this month i've started releasing some
things on des cartes discourse on method
which is you know always a great text to
explore so that you might find
interesting and since it's Black History
Month i'm actually going to skip ahead
to the last set of videos that i'm
shooting for the course i'm going to
skip over some of the stuff in that
that's from Descartes to to this and I'm
going to release some videos on Martin
Luther King's works letter from a
Birmingham jail and the I have a dream
speech and then I'm going to start doing
some more critical thinking videos i'm
still midway through the fallacies
there's there's about another 20 or 30
of those that i need to shoot so i'm
going to start getting those back up and
running and start thinking about what
else should go into the critical
thinking channel got some more writing
projects going on if you're if you're
interested in the kind of work that i do
with the blogs now would be a good time
to start you know checking them out i
usually publicize that on my Google+ on
my facebook page and my twitter but i'll
be doing a lot more writing i'm at work
right now on two different papers on
saying
and some both of which are involving a
revision process and adding things in
one is still that courteous homo justice
mercy paper the other one is revising a
paper that I gave at a conference
several years ago about st. Anselm's
moral theory it's time for me to expand
that and start sending that out to two
other journals for publication working
out a lot of Aristotle material mostly
centered on Aristotle and anger but also
some other things as well so I'm doing
some work on the Aristotle anger book
I'm doing some work on some Aristotle
papers I'm revising a Hobbes paper for
publication that won't be happening this
month but probably will be coming out
sometime in the spring so that's kind of
exciting i'll talk more about that in
another one and i'm still working on
this this good life chapter for this
this textbook that was proposed and i'm
hoping to get that off my plate very
soon I'm also writing a paper on
somebody who have never written on
before but I've always been quite
interested in and that's Mary
Wollstonecraft you know i'm interested
in virtue ethics and i'm particularly
interested in her conception of virtue
so i'm working out a paper on that that
i'm hoping to submit to to a conference
to get accepted so i'll talk more about
that after after it's done so that's
what we've got going on in February you
can tell it's quite a bit like I said if
you can make the public events I'd be
happy to see you there and if you're
there stick around afterwards and I'll
you know chat Fur for a few minutes at
the kingston ones i can chance for as
long as I like the New York City one I
you know I'll have to get going soon
afterwards but it's great opportunity to
interact with with people who are
interested in the kind of work I'm doing
if you're interested in tutoring or a
philosophical counseling you know
contact me best way to contact me is
Greg at reason
I Oh calm and if you're interested in
booking me for for public speaking or
suggesting to somebody else that they
should book me for public speaking I
think you know if you follow my channel
you know the kind of range of topics
that I can cover you know what I'm like
as a public speaker so you know again
same thing with that Greg at reason I Oh
calm if you've got an invitation for me
or if you're suggesting me to somebody
keep me in the loop oh so that's it for
februari and what took place in January
big month coming up and so now I got to
get to work